welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain I'd like to introduce dr.
Elizabeth Buffalo she is professor of
the department of physiology and
biophysics at the university of
washington as well as chief of the
neuroscience division of the Washington
National Primate Research Center she
will be presenting in our brain
initiative scientific updates track on
how the human brain learns to learn for
a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen my name is dr.
Veronica Shannon and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab words we
would also like to extend our special
thanks to the program directors of the
brain initiative in particular dr. James
mad for their efforts in organizing
today's session before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting questions
during the presentation simply click on
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen and type your
questions in the drop-down box we will
also be offering a unique opportunity to
directly address awardees of the
research on humans division of the brain
initiative this slide panel Q&A will
take place today at 9 a.m. Pacific time
12:00 p.m. Eastern Time dr. Buffalo's
presentation is educational and this
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Elizabeth ah
hello I'd like to thank the organizers
for inviting me to participate in this
webinar and to describe some of the main
goals of our u-19 grant and which is
supported under the brain initiative and
also be presenting some of the early
preliminary work from from our research
so the overall goal of this research
program is to try to understand how the
human brain learns to learn the brain
has a remarkable ability to store and
retrieve information so detailed
memories can be formed after as little
as one exposure and those memories can
be
for decades importantly recent studies
have demonstrated the critical role of a
mental schema or a learned cognitive
structure in supporting rapid memory
formation so in this example after
having many experiences of going
shopping in a grocery store we've formed
a mental schema of the store that can
help us quickly recognize the overall
behavioral context of this market and it
also helps us quickly identify items in
the scene and in practice our mental
schema facilitates our ability to find
items and to form new memories of the
locations of particular aisles even if
we're shopping in a new store in essence
is previously acquired knowledge
provides a framework that shapes how
ongoing experience is perceived and
remembered and this resonates with older
ideas from neuro psychology of learning
to learn as a mechanism by which rapid
learning might be accomplished so the
idea behind learning to learn is that if
you encounter multiple tasks that have
that shares some common aspect across
tasks then this enables learning of the
structure which is common to the
learning set which will then facilitate
learning on new tasks and commonalities
across tasks may come analogies at
stimulus structure including either the
sensory modality that's involved or the
particular attendant features that are
important for the task a learning set
can also involve commonalities in the
structure of the decision or choice
space that the subject might be making
commonalities at the temporal structure
of the trial including aspects like when
to expect stimuli or delays and when the
subject is able to make their choice and
there could be commonalities in the
computational structure including what
kind of information is important to
maintain in working memory and how to
map that information onto choices
importantly we're interested in the
nature of that mapping function which
could then be leveraged in order to make
inferences about stimuli when they're
observed for the first time that is in
order to be able to have rapid new
learning so in this example through the
learning of individual problems which
are shown at the bottom
the subject can develop a learning set
as shown at the top and this learning
set represents the rule that on each
problem one stimulus will be rewarded
and one will not and this process of
learning to learn is thought to
facilitate new learning by reducing the
dimensionality of the space that the
organism has to search in order to adapt
to new to novel problems so one exciting
paper that was just published last month
from Sylvia Worth's lab demonstrated the
existence of schema cells in the
hippocampus so these are cells that
showed a similar representation across
mazes that the monkey navigated and
these mazes differed in their specific
visual features but they shared a common
structure and in this study monkeys also
showed rapid learning when they
encountered a new maze possibly because
of the development of a schema for the
mazes and the task structure and the
development of a schema that supports
this kind of rapid learning is thought
to involve I don't know this but
interactions between the hippocampus and
the neocortex
however the neural circuitry that
underlies this kind of rapid one trial
learning is not well understood so an ru
19 program we're using innovative
techniques for recording in monkeys and
we're also using single unit recordings
in human envelope C patients and we're
capitalizing on the unique opportunity
to establish cross species comparisons
of hippocampal neocortical interactions
and the three primary goals of our
research program are shown here and they
are to identify the neural mechanisms
that support schema development and
rapid learning in monkeys and Kieran's
we aim to develop and validate novel
techniques for large-scale recording
from recordings from multiple
distributed regions of the human and
non-human primate brain and we'll be
doing this during learning and also
through reversible and activation in the
non-human primate and during sleep in
both monkeys at humans and then finally
we aim to generate and test a multi
region computational understanding of
circuit mechanisms that underlie schema
development as
rapid learning so this slide shows the
types of interactions and collaborations
that exist across our United program
experimental work shown in the middle of
the slide will be carried out in monkeys
in my lab as well as in the lab of Dave
Friedman and at the bottom is the work
in human epilepsy patients and this is
carried out with Robert night Jacqueline
and Jeff Oh German and these recordings
and humans will be carried out using
identical behavioral tasks as those used
in the monkeys as well as many
overlapping brain regions so one of the
benefits of research and not human
primates is that monkeys can be trained
to perform as complex tasks of learning
and memory that are identical to tasks
that we'll use with the human subjects
and I think this is a particular
strength of our cross species approach
these experimental findings will be
incorporated by joshing Wang's shown on
the left in to computational models that
will provide further theoretical insight
and will motivate further experiments
and then on the right our data sight
score which is led by Adrian fair hall
at REO Rome will provide computational
and theoretical insights into circuit
dynamics and will aid all of the
projects and the management and sharing
of these really large neural data sets
so again our central questions are how
is learnings that represented in the
primate brain and how does an establish
learnings that facilitate rapid new
learning so our standards set up in the
nonhuman primate is shown here so in
these experiments we have the monkeys
seated in a primate chair while we're
recording neural activity and we have
the monkeys viewing and interacting with
stimuli presented in front of them on a
computer monitor in the case of the
recordings with human epilepsy patients
will use laptop computers at the bedside
with patients who have electrodes
implanted as part of seizure monitoring
and one task that we've been using with
both the non-human primates and the
patients is shown here this is the
Wisconsin card sorting task
example of the display of this task is
shown on the top left so on each trial
subjects are presented with four stimuli
that are comprised of different features
which include color shape attack and the
subjects task is to learn through trial
and error which feature happens to be
the target feature within a given block
of trials so the square on the right
around stimuli indicate the subjects
choice on each trial so this is showing
a series of trials or going from top to
bottom and left to right and the green
square represents the correct trial and
the red square represents the incorrect
trial so what this is showing is that
through trial and error the subject was
able to converge in the last three
trials on an understanding that blue was
the target feature and they didn't need
to pay attention to shape or the texture
of the stimulus in this task after a
subject reaches a criterion level of
performance on a given rule then the
rule will be switched without any
instruction to the subject at that point
the some people need to learn again a
new rule through trial and error so we
found that monkeys and humans can
perform this task
monkeys are able to learn new rules
within each session they can learn about
30 to 40 new rules and they can do this
with both intra and extra which would
indicate a switch within a given feature
but is either color shape or texture but
switching between specific instances of
that feature while an extra dimensional
shift would include as switching across
features the monkeys can perform this
task taking about 30 trials to reach
criterion for each switch and human
subjects also perform this task really
well taking about 10 to 15 trials to
reach criterion
analysis on this task can involve both
measures of trials two criterion and how
many switches the subjects were able to
perform within a given recording session
but we can also look at the rate of
learning
which is shown here so the top graph
here represents a rule that was learned
in a stepwise manner with a very sharp
transition between making incorrect
responses is shown on the bottom and
correct responses at the top of this
figure while the lower graph shows the
learning of a rule that happened more
gradually and we will be assessing
neural activity that is associated with
these distinct forms of learning as I
mentioned we've developed novel
techniques for large-scale recordings
throughout the monkey brain so this is
shown on the Left we can record
throughout the medial temporal lobe as
well as the prefrontal cortex and the
slides on the Left show our target
regions on an MRI at the top of a monkey
brain so we have one drive that targets
the hippocampus and the surrounding
medial temporal lobe cortex and then we
also have an anterior drive that allows
us to sample from multiple regions
within the prefrontal cortex on the
right you can see typical coverage for a
human patient so we have recording sites
throughout the prefrontal cortex as well
as recordings from deep in the medial
temporal lobe at the hippocampus and the
amygdala and these include electrodes
that have micro wires for seeing the
unit recording so what's exciting is in
these experiments we can record single
unit activity as well as the local field
potential from homologous brain regions
in monkeys and humans while they're
performing exactly the same task so this
slide just shows some of our preliminary
data this is the activity of a single
unit recorded in from the anterior
cingulate cortex of a human patient and
this was an interesting
neuron which showed that feedback
sensitive neural response so in this
figure and the green line at time zero
represents the time of feedback to the
patient on each trial and this neuron
showed an increased firing rate for
incorrect trials shown in red compared
to correct trials which is shown in blue
the figure on the right shows the
waveform recorded from the single neuron
so our preliminary work has shown
similar kind of responses
in other areas of the prefrontal cortex
as well as in the hippocampus in both
monkeys and humans and we're currently
working on analyses to investigate how
this kind of activity as well as other
task related responses might support the
formation of new learning in this task
another kind of behavioral task that
we're going to be using is motivated by
older work from Harlow from 1949 where
he showed that over the learning of many
different problems there was the
development of a learning set so through
experience with many different
discrimination problems the monkeys were
able to get better and better in the
sense of taking fewer trials to learn
each new discrimination and after
experience with hundreds of these kinds
of problems as shown in the very top
line the monkeys were able to learn
essentially within one trial the new
discrimination problem in our version of
this this is shown on this slide the
monkeys have been trained to associate a
position either making a left or right
word saccade with particular stimuli
that are presented at the center of the
screen and this is work from Dave
Friedman's lab where they've been able
to show that monkeys are able to
demonstrate this kind of faster and
faster learning through successive
discrimination of problems so what this
is showing is that by the end by after
they've learned about four or five of
these pairs the monkeys were able to
take just a very few number of trials in
order to reach criteria on this task and
so the question is what kind of neural
activity might support formation of this
kind of schema and we want to we want to
understand this by using this kind of
task as well as other tasks that
required the monkeys to make
associations between stimuli and colors
and then also see if they can then as
shown in the bottom make the inference
between this kind of categories that
have been associated and then whether
they could show rapid new learning if we
try to teach them about new stimuli and
as rapidly assimilate them into these
different categories now in terms of how
the hippocampus and the prefrontal
cortex might work together and so
or memory formation and schema
development one hypothesis is that this
interaction may be coordinated through
fast oscillations about these are sharp
wave ripples that are at about 120 Hertz
and these sharp wave ripples have been
implicated in previous studies in
learning and memory across species so
we've been able to identify sharp wave
ripples as shown here in both monkeys
and humans during periods of sleep so on
the left you can see examples of these
hippocampal sharp wave ripples recorded
from a monkey during a rest period
following task performance and then on
the right you can see an example of a
sharp wave ripple recorded from a human
epilepsy patient this was also recorded
during sleep some new work coming out of
Bob Knight's lab and work with Jaclyn
has shown that that this prefrontal
hippocampal interaction during sleep is
important for memory consolidation so
what I'm showing here on the left
represents in red spindle this is a
spindle that was recorded in the
prefrontal cortex and showing that it
occurs or it's preferentially nested on
the peak of a slow oscillation recorded
through EEG the slow oscillation
represents the Upstate and what they
demonstrated was that this coupling
phase the precise phase synchrony of
this spindle with the slow oscillation
predicts overnight memory consolidation
and then on the right this is showing
that optimal coupling actually induces a
multiplexed bi-directional hippocampal
prefrontal cortex connectivity so the
blue line represents the optimal
coupling between the spindle and the
slow oscillation and these data suggest
that when this optimal coupling is
associated with data frequency this is
related to stronger connectivity from
going from the hippocampus to the
prefrontal cortex and during the spindle
frequency it's associated with stronger
connectivity from the prefrontal cortex
to the hippocampus and so we're going to
be associated to be investigating these
kinds of signals a
across our behavioral tasks that I just
described and then also in monkeys to
see if we can identify the same kinds of
signals in the non-human primate where
we'll have a better ability to localize
the units to particular regions
throughout the hippocampus and also
within the prefrontal cortex and then
all of this work feeds into some of the
work in judging Wang's lab which will
help in providing theoretical insights
into the circuit mechanisms that support
this work and some of the goals in
involves a training recurrent neural
network models that are capable of
learning to learn that can qualitatively
replicate our experimentally observed
learning set performance curves and then
they'll be analyzing these recurrent
neural network population and also the
single unit activity which will allow
them to generate hypotheses and
experimentally testable predictions that
then we'll be able to test in our
recordings again in monkeys and humans
and then we'll also be as I mentioned
analyzing the model and generating
hypotheses and experimentally testable
predictions and recently advances in the
modeling of these recurrent neural
networks provide a very promising
framework within which to interpret the
kinds of complex data that we'll be
gathering and by training artificial
networks to perform the same tasks as
our experimental subjects these learned
dynamics can serve as a plausible
Network implementation of the cognitive
computation so we can then examine these
networks to discover hidden dynamical
structure of these computations and we
can also develop hypotheses for how the
biological network may implement them
and finally all of this work is
critically dependent on a strong data
science core and so one of the exciting
aspects of this synergistic approach of
these experiments is that we have
similar kinds of experiments running
across species and across laboratories
so we need ways of establishing data
standards as well as ways to facilitate
data sharing
we're working on this is work with
aerial row command Adrian Fair Hall
they're working on development of
computational tools that will allow us
to have collaborative development of
these tools across laboratories we're
going to have shared common
computational environments and also
scalable computing so as you can imagine
the data sets that will be collecting
from these experiments are extremely
large and so we'll have to be able to
manage them at this and to be able to
scale all the solutions that we that
were implementing and then on the right
you can see what we're going to end up
with again is obviously publishing the
work that the data that results from
these experiments but also sharing the
data and sharing the the code that was
used to to analyze the data again hoping
for greater transparency and also
replicability and maybe generating data
sets that could be used to inspire
future experiments so the overall goal
again of our Uniting program is to
develop a comprehensive theory of the
circuit mechanisms that underlie the
human brains ability to establish neural
frameworks that enable rapid new
learning so the overall goal of this
Uniting program is to develop a
comprehensive theory of the circuit
mechanisms that underlie the human
brains ability to establish neural
frameworks that enable rapid new
learning and I just want to acknowledge
both our funding sources through the
National Institutes of Neurological
Disorders and Stroke as well as the
brain initiative and I'd like to
acknowledge the members of the team who
are contributing to the work so the
experimentalists shown in the middle
include my lab as well as the lab of
Dave Friedman and then at the bottom the
work is with from human patients is with
Jacqueline Bob Knight and Jeff Bowman
and on the left
Xiao Jing Wang who's leading up our
modeling efforts and then on the right
Adrian fair halt and Arielle Roca who
are leading up the data science core and
so thank you for your attention they
dr. Buffalo for that very informative
presentation as a reminder our speaker
will be able to follow up any specific
questions in the live Q&A at the end of
this track
coming up next dr. Lucas Howser will
continue the scientific updates of the
brain initiative with a presentation on
deciphering the neuronal mechanisms of
the human episodic memory at the single
neuron level and don't forget to join us
at 9:00 a.m. Pacific time 12:00 p.m.
eastern time where we will be offering a
unique opportunity to directly address
awardees of the research on humans
division of the brain initiative we look
forward to seeing you there